Hello
everybody, hello, hello, I'm sorry for the late waiting
room, I literally woke up from my hibernation right after
yesterday, I was really react out.
I guess like yesterday, I might react a little too hard
yesterday, oh my god guys, oh reacting such a hard thing to
do on stream.
hardest thing I've ever done in streaming in my life um I
was reacting Andy is serious work guys you I know it's I the
most unexpected thing ever um anyway give me a second I'm
gonna take a bite of my chocolate boo-boo I need to finish
this chocolate boo-boo um I haven't eaten yet so this is my
this is my meal for now but I'm waiting for my food it's so
difficult guys
Guys, six hours, six hours of non-stop reacting, guys.
I don't, I'm truly the hardest thing ever in life.
And hardest job out there, guys.
Oh my God.
Imagine trying to what, like, all I'm saying.
of all the jobs in the world six hours of reacting truly is
cannot be compared to anything else um that's why i do it so
you guys won't have to uh don't worry i will take the
sacrifice for all of you um so i thank you for the gift one
gifted chip thank you thank you super chat thank you thank
you already got a streamer ticket streaming ticket it was a
very Japanese experience thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you I know I know don't worry you're welcome
you're welcome I'm I'm I thank you for your I know thank you
for my service I God gave his strongest soldiers the hardest
jobs but no I just passed out right after after I got um
after I ate mac and cheese I ordered mac and cheese for
dinner and right after I just passed out and I think I just
slept like 12 plus hours you know what I'm sorry to my
manager in advance I should have said I mean I could have
said sorry in our Discord DMs but I'll say say sorry in on
stream you might not be watching this you might not be
watching this I could have just told it to him in DMs, but
sorry in advance to my manager.
Yeah, public apology.
So we all know a live apology.
So you know it's sincere.
He was like, when you're awake, we gotta get in call.
We gotta get in call to go over some stuff.
So I'm awake now.
React, Andy is easier on stream than on stream.
to him off stream I oh look he's yeah there you go he's here
um so um anyway unfortunately I am awake now but
unfortunately I have to stream now so maybe you'll catch
don't worry I'll stay up this time I'll stay up so then we
can have our little talk I know this could have been a DM
I'm sorry at the...
I'm just like, this could have been a DM dokey.
But, hey, at least you hear live from me, you know?
It's a more...
It's a more sincere connection.
It's not...
I'm not doing it via text, you know?
I'm doing it via call instead where everyone's watching.
So at least you have witnesses.
I will stay up.
Hey, I'm giving him witnesses.
I will stay up later tonight.
So we can get in a call.
And...
So yeah, I passed out.
And I woke up and like...
Oh, he's now playing Deadlock after that.
I just literally see my manager.
After my apology, my manager booted up Deadlock.
And he's like, alright, that's good to know.
I guess I'll go to Deadlock now.
And you blame him.
so that's why that's why the waiting room was also really
late because I also forgot to tell my manager to make my
waiting room because you can't make it without a thumbnail
um um so so I woke up and I was like oh shit I was like oh I
woke up 1220 I woke up at 1220 and I was like oh fuck okay
that's not good I just said alarm because I didn't think I
would late because I finally reset my sleep schedule finally
I fixed it so for those who didn't know my sleep schedule
has been like really fucked up for at least since I came
back from Korea so I've been on an Asia time schedule for a
while now because for some of my body I don't know it was
just really hard adjustment and I also have been grinding
Street Fighter a bit too much so I've just been playing
Street Fighter late at night as well so now that like Street
Fighter is fighter week is finally over my body can finally
rest at normal hours now so i don't think my body is used to
be sleeping that much because they're like my body's like
wait more than three hours of sleep that means you can go
you can never that means you can wake up after 20 hours so
um i would i thought that would wake up after like seven
hours of sleep but i was just out out like I my body was
like never wake me up because it was like I guess it was
like trying to catch up with all the sleep set that I that
I've unfortunately accumulated over the last two weeks from
Street Fighter grinding so I didn't sell them lime obviously
because I didn't think I would be knocked out for that long
and then yesterday I felt like you know I treat it dad to
the bedtime to like the i treated dad to be like you know
what i feel good today dad um you know usually dad would
wake me up you know for food you know it's like for
lunchtime or like walkies but last night last night i was
just like you know what dad i feel good today i will let you
on the bed you know today is the day you get to be back
you're like Like, timeout is over.
Like, you're no longer banished from the bed.
You shall now experience the luxurious life.
So, yeah, no, dad did not want to leave the bed.
So he didn't wake me up as well.
He was just, he was just, like, passed out with me.
He didn't know when he'll have this opportunity again.
Banishment has been lifted.
So, he also didn't wake me up.
It was just fine.
I don't know how he was able to hold his, I don't know, he
was just like, I could, I don't need to use the bathroom,
I'll just pee on my bed, I guess, I'm glad he didn't pee on
my bed, but, um, but I had to do a quick walkies, you know,
that's why I had to push the stream, I had to push the
stream as well, because I had to do a quick walkies and, um,
quick walkies and food and then setting stream up, um, and
now I'm here, now, Now I am here.
But yeah.
Anyway.
You guys want updates on like Street Fighter stuff and
previous life update.
Check out the Twitch vibe.
Before it's gone.
Before it gets uploaded to Vaughn channel a year later.
I don't really.
TLDR.
If you missed out.
If you missed out on the life update.
Last night.
One.
I went and celebrated with hot pot right after the street
fighter game of street fighter tournament Our team did get
last, but I got my one And I said I was like that meme of
that guy who was like third place and he's popping the
champagne He's like, yeah, that was me, but I wasn't even on
the podium That was That was me But I got my one so like I
went to hot pot to fucking celebrate
and um and after that after that um i also uh talked about
how on the same day it felt like canada day came early
because uh because for those who don't know canada won its
very first game ever in the world cup series and no one
really believed in canada to ever do so because we have
never won a world like we've never won a game in the world
cup we've always been in the qualifiers but we've never like
got out of the group stages or won a game in a group stage
so it was like a huge historical moment so like you know i
got my one it kind of got its one too against guitar so like
you know we're like almost we're like sort of on the same
level
um i had so like you know we're both winning and yeah you
know yay so um you know it was so bad like no one really
believed in canada and like i mean like no i mean if you ask
any canadian we would have we none of us would have been
like yeah canada's gonna fucking do it this year like like
we've we've accepted it for a long time like uh because um
The Canadian games in Canada, by the way, are, like, so low.
Like, not a lot of people are sort of going to the World Cup
games in Canada.
Because, like, especially for Canada.
So there were a lot of tickets up for sale.
And there were also, there was, like, you know, not a lot of
people were traveling to Canada to watch the Canadian game.
So, um, so I debated whether or not, because I could travel
there to watch it, because I was like, oh, it's like sort of
nearby.
Like, I, I, I never seen a World Cup game before, like, so I
was, like, debating about it.
Like, should I, should I go check it out?
Like, it could, and I was like, do I really want to watch
Canada get its ass beat?
Like, because I was like, why should I pay for a ticket just
to watch Canada lose?
i thought about it for a while um and and i was like
so yeah so i was just like i don't know if it's a good idea
and and then the day before can the guitar i made the
purchase because i was thinking i could always resell it
later if i didn't want to do this so because i was just like
i'll just buy a ticket now and I'll resell it later if I
like regret this and then and then Canada Qatar won and won
their very first like Canada Canada won the very first game
ever in history in the ticket prices the tickets prices
tripled right after
so now So now I'm in a little dilemma here.
I could wait a little bit longer.
Because if Canada wins against Switzerland.
If Canada wins against Switzerland.
This will be the very first time.
Not only would it be the very first time Canada has won.
It's like not only has Canada made history by when it's very
first.
first game in World Cup history, in its World Cup history,
it would be the very first time if they win against
Switzerland to make it out of the qualifiers into top 32.
So now I'm a little dilemma here.
Because if I wait a little longer, ticket prices might
quadruple.
If I...
Biggit.
Come on, thank you for the 10 gift of chips.
Thank you.
The sweets.
But you might miss the match, though.
You might be a... You might miss a being a part of history.
So...
anyway um anyway now i have a ticket to a match that might
that might also be another historical moment for canada so
so so uh it could be a part of history yes it could be a
part of history
yeah that's true or they could not make it and i can be a
little i can't it's like invest it's like bitcoin guys i
finally have bitcoin so do i sell or keep do i sell stop
while you're up dokey you can be on the trivia page at the
fifa wiki but anyway and not all of canada believes in
canada not everyone in canada believes in canada because
like i said they we finally so now people are actually
buying tickets now um um there's wild i think like at least
at least 50 of the tickets have now been sold um because
there were so many tickets when i like when i bought this
ticket there were so many seats available um like at some
point like I talked about this on Twitch but at some point
the mayor had to make a statement and was saying how um say
like it was talking about how like you know their hotels
were like there are so many vacancies in hotels and some of
the countries like Qatar was practically giving away tickets
for free and flying people over to For yeah, my tickets on a
good spot too.
I bought a good seat as well So like I remember like I read
that Qatar was flying people in for free and giving away
tickets for free So like they could fill up the stadium For
the Qatar versus Canada match.
I that That's like out.
That's how like That's how sad like ticket sales have been
lately for the ones um for the ones in Canada like it's not
so like because like you know like Canadian we Canadians
thought we're just gonna get our ass beat like always like
it's been we've never won a game guys that's you know how
many World Cup it's been there it's been like 40 plus years
of World Cup and we've never won a game before so it's like
Why would I pay so much money to watch Canada lose again?
Yeah, so that's why, like, after that performance, yeah,
after that performance, ticket sales went so fast.
I literally checked, I was like, oh my God, like, so many
tickets were gone.
already um i don't know let me check now today actually yeah
they were already sorted they were already expensive but
like if you look at us and mexico it's so hard to get
tickets for us and mexico because like the default price for
us and mexico were like already triple the default price for
canada matches because i was looking at it.
Like if you look at the like if you look at the stadiums for
US and Mexico, it's practically almost filled like full
house.
But if you look at the stadium for Canada versus Qatar, it
would...
If you look at the stadium for Canada versus Qatar, it's
like people didn't believe.
Like it's a little sad.
It's...
This is why, like, you would see, like, the shots of, like,
the matches.
They don't try to pan to the stadium.
You can tell when a stadium's empty.
When they avoid panning the camera shots to the stadium.
Because they didn't want to show how many empty seats there
are.
Yeah.
But then if you look at USA and Mexico, it's, like, filled
with people.
And you're just, like, oh, that's a little sad.
Like, yeah.
Let me...
You know, I should check, actually.
Can't...
Let me check what the sales are like right now.
Oh, my God.
What?
So I'm looking at...
Oh, my God.
I'm looking at tickets right now.
also a lot of people scalping too
I'm just looking at I'm looking at ticket options now for it
and oh my God I'm gonna check the hospitality tickets too
I'm money signs in my mind and now
give me a sec let me look at if there's still hospitality
tickets to because there is still the thing is there are
still hospitality tickets for those who don't know what
hospitality tickets are that's like the it's like the VIP
tickets um um for matches let's see where is it yeah where
you can go to like we can go to like the um like basically
like free food and like lounge and stuff oh my god oh man
wait okay almost majority of the hospitality tickets are
sold out now that's insane there were so many like the fact
that even they had like vip tickets that you can
and i might i may or may not have one of the i might have
may or may not have bought a vip ticket because i because i
was just like i want a place to chill if i like you know i
want a place to chill a little i might have bought hey if
i'm gonna watch cat okay my mindset was my mindset was if
i'm gonna watch canada get his ass beat at least i'll watch
it in comfort you know like that's that's where my head was
i was like at least i'll get like at least i'll have like a
place to get some night something good to eat and like like
drinks as well so like i won't have to be like too miserable
like sitting there for it because it's like what it's like
two hours long too like i was thinking i was like it's a two
hour plus match it's 90 minutes yeah it's 90 minutes
sometimes more sometimes it could be more like could be like
120 minutes so i was just like thinking comes with a
memorabilia so like at least i have a memory that actually
was there in person because if i get like a regular ticket i
don't get like this little souvenir or something.
Apparently it comes with a little souvenir that you went to
the stadium for.
So I was just like, I mean, I get a little exclusive
souvenir.
So I was thinking at least like, hey, at least I get a
souvenir that I was there versus watching at home.
Yeah, you know, like.
And also it will be a bit more comfortable.
And it says that the seat is like better than that normal
seat.
So I was just like, all right.
um if canada doesn't get his ass beat at least i have a good
view of it it canada gets ass beat at least i get a good
view of it and also it's a bit comfortable and i get a
souvenir watching my own country get his ass beat like
and they have free drinks and food so like at least like i'm
sitting there for two plus hours with free drinks and food
so I felt like I might as well go for a VIP option because
if I don't go for the VIP option I'm sitting there for two
plus hours with no food and drinks with no free food and
drinks and watching my country get its ass beat like and
also sitting somewhere very uncomfortable so I was just like
I might as well like make it comfortable like yeah losing
with yeah it should be fine like quote unquote free true but
then i was just thinking i rather like i felt like the lines
too for like buying your food is gonna be super fucking long
so i was just like well if i'm gonna line up for food i
might as well line up for food that like i don't i'm not
paying for i mean you understand that logic like i'm
thinking like well if i'm gonna waste my time lining up at
least i don't have to pay for this food that i'm lining up
for i could make them bring the food to me too i'm pretty
sure i'm pretty yeah so i actually want to see like the
regular ticket sales because there is a resale on the FIFA
page as well so I'm curious how how high it's gone up to so
yeah anyway I might see Canada versus Switzerland next week
so we'll see how that goes I'm definitely won't be streaming
because I have to travel I have to travel on that day so no
streaming on wednesday uh i'll be i might potentially uh
maybe depending on depending on stuff i might be over there
all right give me a sec guys actually so i really want to
see like uh how much the tickets are right now or or okay
where the fuck is it all right fifa
all right not hospitality i don't want to check hospital all
right tickets let's see uh tickets you know what let's see
the marketplace sales right now let's see how that's going
on right now do i need to log in uh or i do need to log in
i failed to capture how do they know i'm not real all right
i actually am curious how far how high the ticket sales are
now for like the ones you for the um uh not on stub hub
all right let's see i'll have to log in all right oh what
the how did i up my thing again I swear I'm real I think I
The FIBA website is so weird It makes you like It makes you
validate Like every time you log in And they're like Please
check your email To make sure you're that person I also have
to Oh I have to I need to download the app It's so weird You
have to download You have to download an app to access your
tickets too it's like you can't access it via uh let's see
you can't like access it via like um the website your own
tickets you have to like download the app they just want
your i guess they want more of your information which is
fine like everyone has my information anyway so uh maybe
maybe it's not fine but like I'm just thinking, you know,
the whole world has my information out.
So, what's, I might as well give it to FIFA too.
Don't say that.
I'm just thinking, I'm like, it's fine.
You can also, come on, FIFA, join in, join in on the party.
I'm pretty sure Google has already sold my data to you.
So, like, oh.
What?
You want it more?
You want it for free this time?
Doki doesn't end up going.
There's always a potential for Doki just watching a video
game FIFA with CPUs against each other and just see how it
goes.
What the fuck is?
Okay.
Any venue?
Nope.
Not that venue.
Alright, let's see how far tickets have gone on the official
resale site.
Please note the prices are displayed below.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Well, oh my God.
Oh my God.
Okay, wait.
I remember the day before the Qatar before the Qatar versus
Canada matches, there was a ticket.
Oh my God, a lot of people are reselling too.
Everyone's getting in on it.
Oh my God.
Everyone's getting in on the resale market now.
So I would be reselling.
I'm sorry.
Oh my God.
A lot of seats are gone though.
So many seats are gone now.
But there was a seat that was in the VIP area.
That was like, I think like one seat was like.
I think it was like, how much was it?
It was like $6,000 for one seat.
I think, actually, no, it was $8,000.
It was $8,000 for one seat in the VVIP area that someone was
reselling for the Cat in the versus Switzerland game.
And they had like four of them there.
And there was four of them there.
And it's gone now.
I don't see it anymore.
I don't see it anymore, guys.
Someone bought it.
Oh my god.
Bro, there's people are selling the shit tickets for $3,000.
Those tickets are so ass-to.
They're like all the way in the fucking back, too.
And they're being sold for $3,000.
I got my hospitality ticket.
Like, my hospitality ticket was, like, was, like, so much
cheaper.
And it's, like, it's in the front rows, too.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
It's time to sell it, but I do.
holy shit it's actually insane how high the prices have have
like soared in like in just the last two days I'm so glad I
bought it the day before the match because I thought about
it too I was just like I debated for so long I was like ah
do I should I buy I was just like I don't know I was just I
was like thinking we're not gonna win like it's just for the
experience because it's like we're never gonna get that like
it's just for the experience because I've never watched a
World Cup game before and now it's like sort of like I could
sort of watch it now like I could travel there and watch it
so it should be like I just wanted to like the experience
just to experience it for the first time you know so I was
like I might as well but as well for just to see what it's
like you know
oh my god just try to see if they they sell like the general
tickets yeah i was gonna say they might not host it again
too so i thought of i just did it for the experience because
i thought they're not going to host it like my like you know
might be like super old by the time they host it again um
and like it wouldn't be the same versus watching it when
you're young so i just did it for like i have the money and
when will i ever get this opportunity again so so i'm just
like oh hey what do you know pot of history now like oh my
god there's a chance i could be a pot of history my my gamma
paid off is this how people felt when they invested in
google
this is like this basically it's like if i invested in
google for the first time in the 1990s oh my god i can't
even access the general sales it won't let me access i i
don't i can't even access the normal general sales for
tickets all they would let me go look at is the marketplace
I've been trying to sign in to look at the general sales to
see if I can buy an actual like ticket from FIFA Not the
resale market and it won't even let me in
Yeah, my VTuber wiki Dokeybird was part of Canadian history
Are you is the last minute sales phase not accessible
all sold out like the last minute ticket page because i i
bought my i bought hospitality tickets so like that's
different watch kind of lose when you show up at least i can
be like at least i'll watch it them lose in comfort though
see these are the type of things that make me think if i
should sell the ticket these these are the comments because
then i would have drupal the prices and i don't have to and
they have to watch and they they're the ones that paid for a
ticket to watch your team lose the kids chat don't make
yourself but what is
anyway other than that other than that uh speaking of
tickets for those For those who don't know, history or
profit, basically.
For those who don't know, streaming tickets are finally out
now.
So for doki-dokie rewind time, for those who can't make it
to the travel, to travel all the way to LA to watch the 3D
concert, we're finally releasing streaming tickets.
So you click on the link pinned in the chat, or I'll just
spam it here we fixed the issue you don't need a Japanese
address anymore to buy a ticket this time um so that issue
is fixed now um and uh the VOD will say you have access to
the VODs until I believe like for like two weeks I believe
it was at the 17th one yeah so you have access to um uh the
concert for at least two weeks um and also the first three
songs of the concert will be streamed for free on my youtube
so uh so if you guys want to see a little preview of the
concert if you're still deciding whether or not to buy a
streaming ticket um there's something i i there's something
i fought for well i don't say fight for it it was more so
like because i didn't have to fight very hard for it like
there was something i requested wanted to have like a free
streaming preview for the people that maybe who can't afford
it or still deciding whether or not to uh uh deciding
whether or not to um to buy a streaming ticket so um just
for those who uh yeah i asked for it i just want my request
that i made and i try i pushed for it really really hard uh
because i've always i want i want you know i want everyone
to have like a chance for those who can't afford it at least
have you got to give you guys like you know something three
songs for free um two or three songs and within the free
portion um will be the nimi uh duet with her so i do have a
duet with nimi and that is going to be part of the free
portion that's also why i took a while to announce her
because i wanted to make sure um that i could get uh her
portion for the song uh for free so it was also uh one of
her requests as well like oh um she wanted to put her poor
duet in the free portion so i had to make sure because if i
couldn't get the free portion we were going to upload the
duet for like duet on the channel uh it was either her
channel or my channel i didn't really care either way i just
wanted to be sure that i was able to get that portion like
the duet with her for free so um so i'm glad i was able to
include it in the i was i'm glad i was able to have a free
streaming portion for the first three songs includes her
duet as part of the free songs for the channel so it'll be
streamed at the same time as the concert itself so you will
be watching it live with the concert so um the concert merch
will be sold online as well guys so do not worry uh I don't
know when it's going to be up on online yet because they're
still the I saw the merch and everything they're still
working on it I guess we're still waiting for like uh some
samples for like one or two merch and I think then they'll
sell.
But yeah, what else do I want to talk about?
But yeah, for those who can't afford to travel all the way
to LA, which is understandable, it's so fucking expensive
right now, you can buy the streaming tickets now.
Yay!
It'll be stocked for the concert, but pre-order online.
We will have the items in stock at the concert.
Yeah, it's in two weeks.
It's actually crazy how soon it's watching the streaming if
you're buying a streaming ticket or watching the free
portion on on my channel um like i said earlier uh it will
be live at the same time as the concert so you're not like
oh like you have to wait a little bit and also um i you can
make gifts of the stuff but no videos or anything if you're
there at the concert or you're watching the streaming
portion you'll have to make gifts of it uh like tiny gifts
of it screen caps or whatever that's cool I should confirm
but like I'm gonna say right now it's cool and I'll message
them just be are we cool with that Yeah, no videos.
It's like the usual rule set you've seen like other Concerts
it's usually like gifts are fine screen caps are fine Um,
and remember to use the hashtag to remember to use the dokey
rewind time Uh for the hashtag of your posting it so like,
you know, it'll be it's like live tweeting the content and
everything Um, so yeah, that's really the general
housekeeping rules um and i hope you guys look forward to
the concert uh i'm really excited about it because like i
said there's so many fun things planned for this concert and
uh i'm really excited yay uh anyway that's it that's
everything now for armor core for real oh my god 40 minutes
of yapping i just realized my voice is a little bit dying
right now um just because like i might have overdone it with
the double tournament double tournaments uh six plus hours
of reacting uh so i realize now my voice is slowly dying um
agent thank you for the super chat thank you thank you be
honest joki how do you like uh i supposed to i almost said
assassin's creed six sorry we were watching there was an
assassin's creed game that got announced yesterday um how do
you like armor core 6 so far.
It's my first armor core game.
I love it.
I love how fast and powerful the ACs feel.
Customization is fun.
I even made Shockwave Optimus Prime in the game.
They give a super chat they get.
Thank you.
It's fun.
I'm enjoying it so far.
It's also my first armor core game.
And honestly, I've been having a lot of fun playing it.
I've been enjoying the mechanics of the game and being a
giant ass tank and go big boom time boom I'm just here for
the big boom all right here we go let's see let me let me
put up the game I don't know why I even like that you guys
convinced me to try anything different It's never worked
out.
Every time I'm like, let's try a new play style, guys.
I always come back to Big Boom.
Like, I know what I am.
Like, then you guys like, guys, what if you have legs,
though, Doki?
Like, what if I have legs?
And then I get my legs chopped off.
Because she hates the whimsy.
Harvard Ad Hort Corp.
The Big Boom only works for so long.
Blasphemy!
How dare you say that?
Big Boom forever.
Jakarta.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
Oh, yo.
Uh, Big Boom is looking for new sponsors.
Would anyone like to sponsor Big Boom?
And boom, that guy.
Oh, wait.
I need to put...
I just realized a lot of my stuff has been like...
Decal.
Has been removed.
Because I added...
Like, I had to get new parts.
Don't worry.
To my sponsors.
I think this one was here.
I remember.
Boob's was here.
Okay.
All right.
And then...
What was the other one?
Okay, I remember...
Where's the...
Right arm, legs, core...
Where's the legs?
I don't want...
Oh, there you are, legs.
And then...
Get $5 on a big boom.
No legs needed.
Only boom.
No one booms for free.
Papa's for a thing.
It was super challenging.
Thank you.
It's fun.
Think of the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Wait.
Let me put on the other ones.
Born the shit forced to wipe.
Okay.
I remember that one.
How did I move the thing again?
I moved.
Okay.
How did I move this around?
I forgot.
It's been a while.
This was...
Try to remember how to move it.
Oh, there you go.
this was in the back i can fit it in the back
they might put it like on the side i'll put it in the front
there you go it's almost working all right that should work
all right what was the new spot can you write little booms
on the chest i'm sorry spun but nsd has outbid you for the
can you write our little booms all right little booms don't
worry i got you oh wait i have to add what is sleep what was
what asleep again i don't remember where where that one was
from the last sponsor oh wait you can't see i thought you
but you can't see the decal i thought that's what you meant
don't worry we can't see i was like what do you mean i can
see the i can see the i can see forced away.
I see it's right there.
It's not that small.
Don't fuck with me.
Ew, he up.
Agent, thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
Oh yeah, I heard about that song.
It's spun by Astroid Music, who also does a mixing for all
my songs too.
One person that helps with the harmonies is the voice of uh
neuro um uh how about chai rainbow rado legends thank you
for super chat thank you thank you he had a little among us
guy too quail think of a super chat thank you thank you
unfortunately it's one sponsor per stream guys and nsd
currently has paid for the hot like like it's like the it's
like the super bowl nsd has outbid you guys for the super
bowl ad spot this is our this is this is our super bowl
right now All right, I need a number of words.
I think it was, like, on the head.
I'm pretty sure.
Let me put it...
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
Oh, I already have it.
It's already on it.
All right, let's add...
What is it?
Little booms.
Okay.
It'll be tiny, too.
We'll make it, like...
Oh, let's make it all cursive.
Oh.
Okay.
Little...
It'll be tiny.
I'll make it all cursive, too.
It'll be a little fancy.
T.
Where's the T?
Little.
Okay, and then we replicate it.
Where's the Q?
Little.
Q.
And then E.
Little.
Where's the B?
We'll make it a little fancy.
Like, oh, look at this typography.
Right here.
Down here.
On the side with a little gap.
Little boom.
Where's the O?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, no.
Where did you go?
Little boom.
Wait, where did the little boom go?
Oh, there it is.
Little boom.
That was so cute.
Wait, that looks so cute.
There we go.
We got little boom.
Little boom is in the house.
I'd like to thank my sponsors.
for the little boom.
Alright, paint.
No, it's decal.
There we go.
Little boom.
Holy shit.
Wait, my mecha has the tiniest fucking head ever.
The tiniest little head is.
Alright, we're ready.
Oh my god, there's so many missions.
What happened while it's gone?
The flow and defend the main missile of the eliminated PCA.
I'll do the elimination one.
I feel like that's the easiest.
I don't know how long I'm streaming.
My voice is a little bit dying right now.
So, I'm not sure.
Because, like, tomorrow I also have like an offline
recording thing I have to do.
Not a song recording.
But, I have, like, work to do tomorrow at the record for it.
Regarding the archivist controlled wall.
Ultimately, both parties were suppressed by the Planetary
Closure Administration.
We'll see how I feel.
I might do like, it might be like a two to three hour stream
type deal.
Just because my voice does feel a little hoarse, which I've
noticed.
I don't have, I don't have any cough drops right now.
I need orders some more.
Be aware that their forces include a new type of craft, the
HC.
That's why we've chosen you.
I'm so special.
It's fine.
I already forgot some of the controls, though.
That's fine.
We'll make it work for us.
Alright, we gotta eliminate some people.
That should be easy.
I'm good at shooting things.
Affiliate, thank you for the five gift of ship.
thank you thank you commence mission eliminate all pca
forces occupying the wall code one five solo a secret boom
oh shit okay i okay guys i realized what my weapons are i i
might have just remembered what i have i was like wait i
have a sword oh yeah we're doing that again haha
It's okay, I remembered now.
Oh, I said as I used my sword again.
I...
It's okay, I remember again.
I've made sure they can't call home for help.
The rest is up to you.
Oh, someone said I have to go backwards for cool things.
Guys, how do I heal again?
I might need to know that, though.
Alright, where are the cool things?
Where is it?
On the right of the ravine.
I'm on the right of the ravine.
Let's see.
Okay, what was the scanner?
Was it V?
Okay.
Who lives here?
Hello.
Any cool, funky dudes that live here?
there's someone cool here.
Where are the cool people at?
Huh?
Hello?
Anybody here?
The right side.
Am I getting warmer?
Am I getting pumped right now?
Nobody cool here.
Marco.
Oh, there you are.
Hey.
They say that the coral is plentiful, infinite.
Before the fires of Ibis.
And then the instant burned.
The planet dry.
The academics in there.
You tricked me to do lore?
That's not cool.
Oh, it's not him.
Oh, he doesn't matter.
Oh.
Okay, okay.
I see how it is.
Oh my god, how guys, how do I?
Oh, I got baited.
I got baited so hard.
I'm trying to focus.
Oh, God, that's not what I want to do.
All right, there you go.
All right, well, now he's dead.
All right, that's fine.
Um, so...
I killed a guy.
Yeah.
All right.
Nice.
It's fine.
We're both in wheelchairs.
You know, it was a fair fight.
Wait, what do you mean there's no resupply?
Alright, now we can go home.
And now we can go do the other actual mission.
Oh, that's not what I wanted to do.
I want... How do I do the rush thing?
Was it controlled?
I think so.
Let's see.
Yeah, it was.
It was control.
Meow.
Alright, he was warm-up.
I had to like, he was helping me remember my controls.
Target.
Where?
It's not talking about me, right?
Oh my god, you cheated!
Okay, that was fine.
No repair kits remaining.
Oh, that's not fine though.
Oh, Shindy's cheating!
He has legs!
That's...
That's fucked.
There we go.
It's fine.
Guys, it's so...
It's fine, guys.
It's fine.
We're so healthy.
I know.
How could you fight me with legs?
wheelchair he's an abeless oh no i'm gonna write google
dockey about this man
okay it's like that 360 fly
all right we're okay i can't believe he would beat up a guy
in a wheelchair
all right accessing level two i am also one hp Oh!
Oh!
Code one five.
Target and reach the facility.
Oh shit.
Where's our patrol?
Yeah, where is our your patrol?
I wonder what happened to him.
Spawn with available forces.
We need time to activate the HZ.
My shoulder ammunition at 50%.
It's fine.
We're still very healthy.
We're so healthy.
I survived.
Yeah, I survived.
Hello, everybody.
I'm here.
Maybe I can snipe...
Oh, shit.
Okay, maybe he can snipe me.
But what if I snipe him first, though?
See, guys?
I just need a snipe him first.
Code two three.
Attending C.
There you go.
That AC must be our independent smirk.
Oh, shit.
Oh, he's so fast.
He's so flat.
Is that fair?
He has a sheet.
I'm in a wheelchair.
I'm going to sue you.
You're going to talk to my lawyers after this.
I don't have a restart project.
play all right so i might okay i'm right here so all right
this time i won't be as stupid
did i hit him i hit him i think yeah yeah i did okay yeah
see i told you this time i won't be as Stupid.
I think I got, yeah, I got him.
Oh shit.
Okay, I didn't get this guy though.
Requesting backup.
Coach 7-8.
All right, this is fine.
And they got him.
All right, where's the other Mecca?
All right, do we fight that other guy again or no?
Should we fight Fuck it, let's try
Does he give me a lot of money
All right If he gives me a lot of money, I'll do it I am a
mercenary for high Where is Where does he show up anyway?
Does he show up after I start reading?
Because that's fucked He took advantage of me in the middle
of reading
Whoa!
He did it again!
Oh my god, we're both in wheelchairs.
There you go.
Guys, how do I activate shield again, guys?
Because I don't remember.
Let me talk to this guy again too.
Just in case.
Control R.
Let's control R.
It's good to know.
It's all right.
We're both in the wheelchair so it's like not a hate crime.
Two repair kits remaining.
Alright, it's fine.
Alright, Control R is the shield.
Hey, Doki, this is distraction.
They paid me to distract you.
Shin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
A little too late.
I got him already.
That's right, we already heard the lore.
It's not the first time we've killed him.
And it won't be the last.
Because I think I'll be back here.
Alright.
see oh yeah it's the two guys is also where i got up too i
got gank done go five target for termination sighted this is
also where they both try to jump on me guys it's okay we
recorded it all
that's right you're getting all it getting it all in video
too
oh my god Oh my god, this was a lot harder, now I remember.
It's okay, we got one.
Okay, come on!
That's cheating!
There you go.
I don't even have to charge that up.
Alright, there you go.
We got it.
You figured it out.
See, warm up over.
move on now.
It's alright, I caught it on camera too.
I'm gonna post it on YouTube.
Being like, they jumped on me.
I was in a wheelchair.
That's right.
Yeah, we still have another repair kit at least.
Alright, knock knock!
The world star!
Whoa!
Ha ha!
Oh shit.
Oh, wait, are they all dead?
Ha-ha!
All units.
External comps have been compromised.
Come on with available forces.
Time to activate the HC.
Big boom!
Here we go.
Oh, another big boom time!
I'm not worried you're running for, huh?
You're scared of the big boom?
Oh, he's actually hiding.
He's scared.
It's like, not me!
Stop!
You knew what was coming for you All right We'll go again Do
I get the guy with a big shield?
Can I get that snake?
Yeah, I do Whoops, I got myself though Ah fuck
It's fire so got it That's right.
You're too late.
They're all dead.
That's right.
Oh, your friends are dead.
Oh, no.
Oh, he's angry.
Oh, I might have pissed him off.
Oh, my God.
Why are you running?
Okay, this is not fair.
This is actually not fair.
there.
There you go.
Got him.
Oh, he's got me though.
He's got me.
Are you serious?
You fucker!
That's it.
I have shield two.
What you gonna do about that, huh?
No repair kit.
Oh, I used too many big booms.
Guys, I'm running up big booms, guys.
You've made a big mistake, sir.
There you go.
It's five.
Yeah!
Come on, you pay me this extract, so cute.
Should take you for the silver chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's fucking right.
Oh, my God.
I clean it up.
day another boom first try i told you i just needed a
warm-up i just needed a warm-up
mission complete
man i don't know how to like save money i don't know what to
cut my budget got
guys i need help balancing my budget what can i do to fix
this one new message useless bazookas that's like telling me
to stop breathing yeah it's me let me give you some advice
don't settle for being an independent join the right guns
have a career oh my god we scouted guys I'm making a name
for myself eventually the curse will get you you too that's
all don't forget what i said oh my god guys they all saw my
resume they're getting smite they saw my cv all the big
corpos are scouting me out you want me to join their team
all right let's do another mission oh wait what happened to
the where was i had wait what what happened to the other one
i had like four i had like three up left
all right let's see dude deactivate all ecm fog control
devices that sounds fun oh it was a choice between two this
is a personal request i don't even know what the other
choice was i didn't even oh my god i didn't even know what i
picked i just saw kill the other one was not a kill mission
a city floating on the ocean built by the rubicon research
institute ever since the fires that place has been abandoned
it's likely hiding secrets about the coral kept shrouded by
the city's ecm fog oh choices matter oops i hope i didn't
make a bad choice already tried sending in a survey drone
only to lose it in the interference that's where you come in
yeah i just chose Violence.
I wonder if that's...
I wonder if choosing Valence is considered a good choice.
Surely that's not a bad thing, right?
Surely violence is always the answer.
We can be the first ones to identify where the quarrel is
converging.
Alright.
Does it activate all and surveys out of the floating city?
Alright, we're ready.
The ECM fog is quite dangerous with calm until it's
disabled.
All right, I miss having a duo, guys.
I want to have another robo-pal with me to do all the work.
Those were the good old days.
Oh, this fog is pretty bad.
All right, I'm being aware of my surroundings.
Oh, there's someone over there.
I'm being aware of my surroundings.
Oh, shit.
Oh?
What is this?
How do I shut it down?
How do I shut this down?
I just go in.
Oh, shit!
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh.
Oh, I should not have hit it.
Oh, don't.
That was...
Hitting...
Hitting it was a bad idea.
Oh, it's like a pathway.
I thought that was a bot thing.
Guys, don't...
Don't hit the explosive, guys.
It's not overkill.
I'm hacking.
I'm hacking?
Confirmed.
The control device is offline.
Alright, we gotta follow this.
Let's see the other pathway.
Are there any ambushes?
I can't find any data on these.
I'm second thought control.
Wait, is that bad person?
That's a bad person.
Oh my god.
He's so fast.
That's not fair.
He's dodging my big booms.
what if can he dodge this oh he can wait he's so fast where
did he go wait did i kill him no i did not my god he's so
fucking fast that's it i can't beat him i stab him you can't
dodge forever oh my god maybe he can
forever all right where did I come from here all right the
next one should be this way all right here we go oh snipers
are here oh it's like mini snipers they're not like the real
ones oh no they're back no they're back no it's okay I
cannot run this.
That's fine.
You don't fucking...
They're just teeny... They're like little toothpicks.
It's fine.
Oh, it's no longer fine.
What do you mean?
Where the fuck is the... Oh, there it is.
It's alright.
There's just little toothpicks.
Oh, my god.
Okay, we extracted.
Xyla remains fully operational.
The monetary closure administration they're best to hide a
place but I'll find a way out there there soon the only one
who knows are the PCA and and what oh what
wait why did you tell me sooner she's
like hostile is here as I get stabbed two repair kits
remaining kids did you see it and I was like have a knife
embedded in my back the data we found helps to identify
where the last ecm devices i've set a marker for it all
right it's over here we did tell you it's like after the
knife is embedded in my back he's like be careful there's an
ambush since we've been on a mission together without walter
their control device isn't going anywhere we're
all right i'm heading over to the last one now oh it's close
by at least it's not that far all right hacking i'm hacking
this all right hack complete yeah i hear you oh shit well at
least this time they won't just fucking live oh Oh
I have to fight my way out Hello, SOS
Can I stab a ship?
I don't even know.
Did I stab it?
Yeah
I don't know, is it stabbed?
I think I stabbed it?
I think?
Did I stab it?
Can't tell.
It's so hard to tell, guys.
Oh my god, he's just flying away!
He's cheating!
Like, what can I do?
He's using the airfield against me!
Oh my god.
Like, what can I do?
I don't have enough flight to get up there!
Okay, where is he?
There you go.
Alright, it's fine.
I'll just stay down here, I guess.
I'll just look up.
Just look up, I guess.
What?
Holy shit!
There you go.
I stabbed it.
I stabbed it, guys.
I stabbed the helicopter.
There we go.
Big boom.
Big boom wins.
Oh, my God.
I'm getting sniped.
Okay, I'll stay here.
I didn't even realize.
Wait.
Objective, objective, objective.
Like, what?
I mean, that wasn't...
Oh.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh, that's awkward.
That's so awkward.
Guys, I think we're in a bad spot.
Okay.
It's fine.
We just gotta get close.
They'll be fine.
Man, if only these guys helped me out earlier.
Don't worry.
I'm activating defenses now.
They're going to help.
Don't worry.
Threat has been neutralized.
Now is the perfect time to activate it.
Here we go.
Oh my god, I'm too fast.
Too fast.
Alright.
That's all right, my little buddies can now be even, can now
be safe, guys.
I'm just trying to keep them alive.
All right, now they can do the work for me.
Oh, you think you saw me?
Go do your thing!
I'll chill here!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoops.
Yay!
We did it, guys!
Where's the last guy, though?
Where are they shooting at?
Oh, he's all the way over there, guys.
Wait, maybe I can snipe him.
Wait, I think I can.
Like, right here.
No, it doesn't go that far.
But unless...
To go that far?
Oh, no, it doesn't.
Alright, don't worry.
Go forth my little minions!
Go!
That would have been cool if I could snipe that.
Technically snipe it here.
Yeah.
Alright, he's dead.
That should be all of them.
Unleash the bees.
Get him!
Alright, yeah!
We did it.
Can't wait to see how much I get paid now.
Oh, wait, hey.
Still a pretty good amount.
Yes.
I think it's still pretty good amount.
Not too bad.
It's not too bad.
Only one-third of my money got instead of half.
You know, I'm getting better.
Yes, I'm getting better at this.
Only one-third.
I see that as an improvement.
defense systems were still in operation after all this time
and strangers still i should be allowed to keep my bees
because i didn't let them die to the helicopter there must
be more to xylem and to wilter's friend oh okay see yeah
don't even need anything new i feel like my my mech is like
optimal right now they gave gun.
Yeah, but is it really better than than what I have now,
though?
Yeah, but like, is it really better than what I have now,
though, guys?
Is it really better than Big Boom?
Come on.
Like, what's more optimal?
Think about it.
Is it this one?
Special missile launcher creates a chain of delayed
explosive with the missile's trajectory allow for sustain to
press fire even against is it this does it give us a bigger
boom bigger boom all right we'll test this out all right i'm
believing in your bigger boom theory
press r to check all right how big is this boom oh that is a
pretty big boom okay but what about this boom though you
know that is a pretty it has more booms it does have a lot
more booms all right we'll test out this boom out to see you
i'll give you one one boom to see no those sucks so bad it's
awkward to position yeah what is it on the boom tier list
Guys, how is it on the boom?
I will say, this does have more power.
I will say, Songbird outclasses it by like 90%.
I give it like three big booms out of 10.
All right, we'll try one of them out.
Do I need to buy anything?
optimal right now.
Like, what do I even need to get?
Like, wouldn't you have better head?
No, like, look at all the other stuff.
I don't think so.
What about, like, body?
Maybe a better chest?
You're all, like, so much weaker, though, than what I have.
Look at generators?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, maybe this Or do I get the VP2OD Or the 20C What's the
generator tier list looking like
The all blue Do we get the VP20C Or the 20D
20C might be better I will get the 20C then Alright Alright
What is this?
20D for heavy build?
Already bought.
You don't want to fuck it.
I'll buy another one.
I'm rich right now.
Buy this too just for fun.
Alright, let's grab the generator.
I don't want to put generator on.
Is this one?
No.
Oh, there it is.
Alright, we'll buy.
We bought the 20D.
Because you guys said it's better.
for a heavy build and this is very very heavy all right
let's see what about like arms so once i should get better
arms but is there any arm that's actually better than what i
have
new fcs what the 155
legs as well but my legs are so good
Talbot?
All right, we'll grab a Talbot.
Um...
All right, we got that.
All right, we're gonna go with this for now, and then go
into a mission.
Jessica, they give us super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I didn't know you were a polymath.
Thank you, a super chat.
Thank you.
I've got a job for you.
Got a job for me?
The PCA show of force has finally started to...
my own business those spineless coyotes jumped at the chance
to become their lackeys now they're feeling ambitious and
sniffing around RAD territory again
I'd say this calls for fireworks and I've got something
that'll blow them away the coyotes can't be ungrateful
though they're bound to come running to stop the launch oh I
forgot what mission was i just clicked on it because it was
the last one oh it's defense mission oh make sure the
coyotes and the pca get a chance oh i don't think i'm built
for defense i'm only built to bash my head until something
happens i defend the main missiles of the uh until the
launch sequence completes okay all right let's see if
there's works i don't know if my build is built for built
for defending my build is more so like i stuffed my booms
into someone until a big boom comes out use big booms to
defend bigger booms
that's true that's true the best defense is offense you're
so right started without you tourist where is my position I
suppose they're an ego bunch oh my god I'm a little bit
faster I'm not used to this how did I get so fast oh my god
who would have known the newer parts made me faster who
could have predicted that all right that's no way You're
telling me if I go a little, if I have new parts, I can go
fast?
No way.
We're all set, Chief.
Commencing missile launch sequence.
Oh, yeah.
You haven't met.
Chatty's our systems admin.
Oh, I know I'm overburdened.
I'm fine with that.
I'm okay with that.
As long as I can have all my shit on, it's fine.
Can I aim this?
Well, technically I can, but I wasn't aiming earlier.
I'm...
There, see?
I told...
Oh, wait, what?
Oh!
Whoops!
Okay.
I might have wasted stuff.
Oh, whoops.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
I was just testing stuff out.
I'm testing stuff out, guys.
He's doing a little, it's like, those like military tests,
you know?
I'm testing my gear.
They're coming from the bridge.
What are you gonna do, huh?
Fucking run past me?
I watched this, guys.
When are they?
Wait, when are they...
No, maybe I just shoot this down.
Oh, I could...
Oh, yeah, maybe I should have just shot it down.
Oh, shit.
Hey, guys.
There we go.
I think I should have shot in the shot.
Oh shit.
Maybe I should have just shot them down.
Wait, we lost something?
Oh, I fucked around too much.
Sorry.
Sorry I fucked around.
I'm so sorry.
Toy box mechs.
One of our spicier products.
Take them out first.
I might have fucked around and found out.
Wait, what?
That's these guys, not that.
Is that it?
Oh, wait, no, you're alive.
Ooh.
Missile launch sequence at 50%.
We're still alive.
I was almost ready.
Don't fail us now, tourist.
I didn't know I was messing about.
To let it through.
left shoulder the ammunition at 15 i'm sorry i
fucked around and found out
who could have known you guys would have known you guys knew
who could have known you guys knew
all right see told you guys my build is not not here to
defend it's just here to go yeah maybe i think i have to go
back to double somberds double somberds has always worked
out for me that
kill this
don't do me no i cannot
all right there's one more over there wait is he Is that guy
over there?
Yeah, that is the guy over there.
Couldn't tell earlier.
He was so tiny.
We lost the second one!
We got the main missile left, Taurus.
Guard it with your life.
What do I do?
Oh, shit.
Wait, hello.
Missile launch sequence at 19%.
Just a little more.
Last push, Taurus.
Alright.
Where?
Did I shoot it?
Ah!
I'm trying to shoot it!
Can't launch a rectum as a tourist.
Oh my god, I can't shoot it!
What a dud.
Consider this mission failed.
No!
I didn't know!
I'm shabbing, I'm stabbing it!
please I thought I thought the ship was just cosmetic I
thought it was cosmetic guys I thought I thought it was just
decorations I was like look at the spaceship look at it it's
so big Tokyo
has giant lasers I don't know I'm I thought I was just
chilling.
I thought I thought I was just chilling and I was just
having hanging out.
Would not Rick and I thought we were just hanging out guys.
Oh yeah, we haven't met.
Chatty's our systems admin.
Doesn't talk much, but he knows his stuff.
Okay, I didn't know where the HP was.
To be fair.
We've got coyotes to deal with.
Never thought they'd end up palling around with the PCA.
Smart, but not for long.
You mean the giant ship with lasers?
Yeah, you know, I thought we were just hanging out, you
know?
I was like, damn.
I thought we cool like that.
I don't know, I thought we cool.
And Doki get up on the hide just back.
They're there.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I was like, damn, bro.
I thought we're getting drinks later.
I thought we cool.
Are we not cool, bro?
What happened?
Don't let them slip past you.
I got where?
Alright, nice.
We got what?
We got another?
I'm just gonna do that one just in case.
Oh, no.
No!
It's fine.
I still have these.
We got big booms.
There you go.
I'm not fucking around now, guys.
Look!
I'm not fucking around the staff!
I'm actually fighting back.
See, nothing to worry about.
Guys, you hired me for a reason.
Look,
see guys?
Look, see?
I'm actually, I'm playing the game now.
I'm not testing stuff out.
No longer letting them take everything.
Serious?
There you go.
They are?
Oh, they are.
Oh, shit.
Our last one!
No!
for us.
Do your job, Taurus.
What do you mean?
Why don't you do your job?
I used everything I had.
I boomed everywhere.
What more do they want for me?
Guys, if I had two Sombards, though, it would have been
over.
You know it.
I'm just lacking the double Sombard.
I knew trying something different was not it.
Every time.
every fucking time I try something new it backfires every
single time
a worship looks like the bigger dogs have arrived oh no
don't let it burn you batter up tourist you've blown up a
worship before right Oh, yep, I have.
Okay.
I'm trying to.
I'm stabbing the ship.
I'm stabbing it.
Okay.
That's the stuff.
Thanks for the pre-show tourist.
Use the launch sequence.
Complete, Chief.
There we go.
I stabbed the ship.
Worship down.
Here come the fireworks.
I punched the ship down.
See, I told you I know how to lock in.
Yeah, I did it.
Committed another war crime, but we are on the good side of
history.
We are on the right side of history, though, guys.
So in the end, it's not a war crime.
And we're the good guys.
Yippee!
Alright, nice.
Didn't waste too much money this time.
Oh, my food's here.
Alright, after we get a report, I'll get my food.
Far too busy for the likes of you.
So I hear.
Must be a tough time to be the Vesper's deputy commander.
Get to the point.
the plan to raid the pca you're going to need more pawns on
the board of course you're here to hawk your services again
very well i'll consider that mutt of yours part of the
effort one more thing show my hound some respect gen 4 is as
good a pedigree as any other so that was such an i'm like
doing a good job too
Oh, new message.
Chatty stick, R-A-D.
Thanks for helping with the file.
Those look like tampons.
I'm sorry.
Chatty's emblem just looks like...
But it does!
Like...
Chatty, but don't you want...
all right yeah new parts all right i'm putting my i knew i
knew i should never big boom i should never left you all
right i'm gonna grab my food real quick guys
i'm ready for my next mission attack the old spaceport
attack the base seized by the planetary closure
administration destroy all the birthed warships min route
rendezvous with friendly craft all right that sounds fine
knife sandwich i didn't think it was super chatting thank
you here's the briefing from my ceo who came up with the
plan okay what is this i shall brief you on the operation
authority.
Consider it a rare privilege.
We will conduct simultaneous surprise raids on two planetary
closure administration bases.
One is the Harlov communications base.
The relay for comms between enemy squads.
The second is the former Bertram spaceport seized by the PCA
for its suppression fleet.
V4 Rusty will be dispatched to handle the Harlov base.
his objective will be to disable their network and prevent
support from PC elite squans Raven during this time you must
destroy all the heavy warships burst as a spaceport okay not
too hard disruption of PCA comms won't last long okay that's
good fast oh my
god he's got my back that's a bro right there
he's got my back guys okay I
mean that seems easy at us enough I just blow things up
that's what I've been doing all the time major blow ignore
V2's snotty attitude just focus on your own work That's not
too bad.
Blowing things up is my specialty.
I think I'm pretty good at doing that so far.
Main system.
Activating combat mode.
Commence mission.
Destroy all the births of warships.
Alright.
Boom!
I didn't expect that, did you?
No one ever does.
I'm on standby near Harlow, buddy.
Catch me in.
I'll gauge the situation on your end before I jump in.
Which is the closest?
Okay, here.
Ha ha ha!
Boom!
Nobody ever expects Big Boom!
That's right.
Don't underestimate me just because I'm in a wheelchair.
That was your first mistake.
Target for termination approaching warships.
Estimated threat range 3 to 4, contain the target.
You can't contain me!
I'll contain you!
Boom!
Whoa.
I'll just stab it.
Fuck it.
Stabbing is faster.
Hey, buddy.
We've taken out the relay mast.
That takes care of their external comms for now.
Keep moving.
Professor Xavier.
Holocaust beam!
For those who are like, what the fuck, Doki?
You missed out on this, um, Twitch streams.
For those who need context, Charles Xavier is an asshole.
TLDR!
No fun!
Target confirmed.
Moving Twitter set.
External cons are out.
Alright, that might be out of for those who don't know that
didn't catch up on the stream.
It may or may not be.
I don't know, context.
Whoops.
What the fuck?
It's really catching up.
Oh, there we go.
It's fine.
I made it.
I had to get up here.
I'm right!
I'm getting closer!
Can't stop me!
Stab!
Looks like you're doing just fine, buddy.
I'm keeping them busy, but they're working fast.
I'm almost there.
I'm at the last, the final stretch.
All right.
Code five.
Intruder detected.
Red level four.
Handle it.
Only four?
I feel like I deserve serve at least an eight.
Come on!
Oh yeah, TLDR.
Charles Xavier is actually a huge asshole.
For those who didn't know, Magneto is a Holocaust survivor.
And at one point, she sent a beam into Magneto's mind to
make him remember the Holocaust.
Which was pretty fucked, bro.
That ain't a bro thing to do.
So that's a TLDR.
What?
Yeah, that happened.
That happened.
Bad news.
The PCA's external comms are back online.
They've got warships heading your way.
Hold out till I reach you.
There's the catch.
Resupply while you can, 621.
Alright, we got rendezvous.
Prepare for enemy reinforcements.
We got rendezvous with Barb, bro.
I'm here, bro.
Where's the meetup?
Where's the meet-and-greet?
Oh, resupply.
Oh yeah, Magneto fucks.
He hooks up with everybody.
Where?
Oh, shit!
Did I get him?
That's not fair.
I should hit him.
Yeah, there we go.
What do you mean?
He's so high up!
Alright, there you go.
Destroyed one.
I might have used up a lot of ammo just to get that one shot
in, but that's fine.
Oh my gosh, how do I reach it though?
Give me a sec.
You're so high up!
Oh, wait.
I can just do this.
I think this reaches him.
Yeah, there you go.
There you go.
It's fine.
I can snipe back.
I don't need no elevator.
Okay, I need an elevator.
Okay.
Where's the elevator?
Where is it?
Oh, there's the elevator.
Here we go.
Give me a sec.
This elevator is not wheelchair friendly, guys.
There we go.
I'm ready.
I told you I'm ready.
Boom!
That's right.
I don't need permission but also please ask consent for the
warship but consent is important
there you go we got it is that everything no there's one
more over there
Almost there.
My tank is just a little bit heavy.
Just a teensy-weezy bit.
Alright, let me recharge.
It's okay.
Go make me big boom!
Oh, shit!
Oh my god, it's fine.
It's fine.
I can take all of this.
Alright.
Permission to board.
Oh,
there's my friend.
Hey Rusty!
Oh wait, his mecca is so cool.
Why doesn't my mecca look as cool as this?
Oh I've got your back, buddy.
Me and the friend you gotta worry about.
understand why does his look so cool compared to mine how
does he do that
okay rusty i might need help rusty rusty i need help rusty
everybody i don't need help i have big booms
like i'm actually making videos though
Wait, where did he go?
Where did he go?
There you go.
Nice.
One down.
Yeah,
that's right.
Should have made my threat level higher than the four.
Oh, where's the other guy?
Oh, there he is.
All right, Rusty.
Distractive, Rusty!
Rusty!
Rusty couldn't distract him!
I missed?
I might have missed?
That's alright.
That's okay, I missed again.
That's okay.
You don't want to fuck it, I'll just use it now.
Where did he go?
He's right above me.
He's so fast.
Rusty's fine.
He's so healthy.
Wait, where did he go?
Was this the entire...
He's so fast.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Yeah!
No!
Rusty kill stole!
Oh my god.
He fucking kill stole me.
That was my kill, Rusty.
I did all the work, bro.
Would be nice, Rusty.
Rusty.
Um, I did all the work here.
I did, like, 90% of that damage.
I've sent you a marker.
There's something there.
Something there.
What is it?
Rusty, do you see that?
Rusty, what the fuck is over there?
What the fuck?
Wait, it's getting closer.
Oh, shit!
Okay, giant worm!
Oh, there's always a giant worm.
There's always a giant worm.
Every time.
I can't get a read on it.
This is bad.
Just focus on staying alive six to one day.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, share.
What?
How?
He's cooking me!
What's wrong?
Oh, he's powering down?
What is it?
I think I might need a bigger boom for this, guys.
They might need a bigger boom.
Convergence?
The coral?
Looks like the PCA has helped itself to the Institute's
relics.
621.
Rest up at base.
I'll come up with a plan to deal with our new friend.
Another job well done.
I did it!
Yay!
Golly, think of the super chat.
Thank you.
If I remember why it's to make...
Magneto realizes plans for P-Cup.
Oh my god.
I think Charlie was just a huge asshole.
IA-02, aka Ice Worm.
It's a sea weapon.
An autonomous deterrent created to protect the crew.
Clown.
Oh, it's the Kodaks of Coral.
I'm gonna fight that!
My pay?
I demand a raise before I do this.
621.
Don't forget we've got a job to do on Rubicon.
I didn't bring you all the way here.
This is beyond my pay grade.
Three new messages.
Well, I'm so popular.
Heard the news, Taurus.
Ice worm, huh?
You just keep tripping up over the Institute's relics, don't
you?
Well, I got something that might interest you.
Yeah?
This is V8, Pater.
Your performance in the spaceport raid was admirable.
Oh my god, I'm getting scouted.
It's like university by the recruiters.
They're giving me all the swag.
They're like, please join my corporal.
fire and are looking to cooperate for the moment oh no
longer rivals for one day I've sent you another request I'm
gonna get a hoodie from their corporation it's like welcome
to Arbus I wonder they I only I wonder if they do like cups
and mugs and stuff too be ranked virtual encounters are now
available in the hmm I'm about B rank now the upper ranks
may these encounters further guide your technique
okay what the fuck trying to press tab but it won't let me
press tab i don't think of a magenta soup but thank you
thank you i try playing controller to prefer keyboard mouse
i think i prefer keyboard mouse just for the aim just for it
even though i know i'm aiming projectiles it's just easier
also be cool a croaky play for a stream since you're a raven
in the game maybe next next part i'll do it i think even a
magenta soup but Thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.
The rivals to lovers.
True, true.
Gus, think of the Super Chat.
Thank you.
He learned you had plot armor and tipped.
Think of the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Alright, next up.
Holy shit.
There's so many new rivals.
Oh, wait.
I stopped here.
I remember.
Wait, but now I'm...
Do I meet the conditions?
What do you mean?
Oh, I have to kill.
Oh, yeah.
I stopped here.
I remembered.
I forgot.
I was like, future doki will handle this.
I forgot about that.
Number 16, rank C.
It's okay.
Now that I have bigger guns and bigger, bigger armor,
that'll be fine.
Call sign, V8.
Commencing evaluation.
I don't need speed.
I just gotta hit the booms.
don't worry something will hit don't something I just need
to hit her once guys as long as I okay maybe more than there
we go I told you oh my god you bitch it's okay I just need
to hit you one time there we go there we go i'll also have
shield too i told you i just need it i just need to hit you
once
future doki did what past doki couldn't
i told you it's all i needed the only hit i need all right
next up bring me the next one bring me the next victim a
veteran independent mercenary who's active in the star
system surrounding rubicon before the fires of ebis so is
the patient gesture one's Oh, generation one.
Or better said, a survivor.
As the technology and its infancy had less than a 10%
success rate.
They escaped the fate of the others.
Sol is followed by a specter of death wherever he goes.
After receiving his surgery, Sol lost interest in most
mercenary work and now lives only for the hunt.
It's unclear who currently employs him.
Oh, he's doing it for the passion.
For the love of the game.
Just like me and Street Fighter.
Guys, I think I...
I think I like made $250 for that Street Fighter tournament.
The Overwatch one was like, it was like, I think it was like
750, like five, was it 750?
Yeah, Overwatch was 750.
I made 250 for the Street Fighter one.
It was like, hey, for the love of the game.
Both were last place too, by the way.
One, I spent like at least 40 hours.
The other was like maybe, maybe like three hours.
Three hours of practice.
Oh shit.
I'm like fucking around here because I don't see him as a
real threat.
I was like, you don't fly.
You don't fly.
There we go.
That's what I'm saying.
I did the Street Fighter for the love of the game.
That's fucking right.
You don't fly.
Alright.
Just face take everything.
I outlived, I know I outlive him.
What is this fucking bubble gun gonna do to me?
He's like tickle damage.
The right hand of Rad's ringleader and chief engineer.
One day, Carla built a simple suggestion-based AI to provide
basic support and occasional entertainment.
However, no matter what conversational prompt she gave him,
he would never say more than necessary.
um instead it seemed that he was content to be a good
listener to his creators free spirits eccentric oh it's
chatty all right let's kill chat let's kill the simulation
chatty
exactly who needs skill when i just have more hp arena
combat aptitude evaluation program number 14 rank c exact oh
shit we're both in oh it's tampon man I mean, look at it!
He even has the strings!
We're both in wheelchairs.
Togey, please.
We're both on one wheelchair.
It's not a hate crime.
We're both...
Look, he missed.
I also missed.
Get close to me.
There we go.
Guess who's better on the sick wheels, though?
Oh, shit.
Okay, he fucked up.
Oh, my God.
He ran away.
Oh, shit.
Okay, maybe I gotta take you a little serious now.
There we go.
Cat dodge this.
Cat dodge this wheelchair on wheelchair violence.
Roger dead.
Overburdened.
What the hell is this?
Hey, I'm winning.
It's called the big boom build.
You can't judge my build if I'm winning.
All right, next victim.
Middle flat will.
The de facto military leader, the Rubicon Liberation Front.
His authority is second only to that of Father Dolmyan.
and is standing within organization has earned him an
informal title as a fellow elder he's the uncle of the
liberation front to dominion's father for a time flatwell
worked as a spy within the extra planetary corporation as
weighed over a rather significant contact in schneider's hr
department he's a double agent
exactly if it's stupid it works then it's not stupid yes
exactly i don't think it'll ever work in PvP, but the AI
doesn't know that.
That's cute.
Wait, his emblem's really pretty.
It's like a free bird.
Wait, where is he?
He's so tiny.
Okay, like I said, I just gotta hit you one time.
Doesn't matter how tiny you are.
It doesn't matter how much you do to me.
As long as your hit once.
holy shit he's so fast oh my god where did he go wait he has
big bombs too that's it that's it oh my god wait that's not
it wait that's not it wait wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute okay oh
my god you bitch no no no no no no it's so fast okay I
figured out the playstyle against them though I figured it
out I figured it out guys I figured out it was because he
was so fast guys that's my only counter it's my only counter
but I know what to do against speed you can't be too fast if
I'm he can wait he can he can though wait a minute oh my god
wait a minute wait a minute he how can he adapt he's he's
learning wait how is this AI learning from me get oh my god
you bitch
Oh my god, this fucker every time!
He downloaded me.
No, I can't let this happen.
We can't let AI win, guys.
We can't let AI win.
We gotta zone him out.
It's like Street Fighter.
Doki, zone him.
But my aim, my missile doesn't have the ring.
though it's like fighting games I just gotta out zone him oh
my god he's stunned me are you kidding me okay okay
I shield two where did he go yes I told you i can also learn
i can also learn i never need to change my build that's
right who needs to change build if brute force will always
win in the end all hell brute force third time's the charm
Nice.
Where did I get it?
You have surpassed rank C.
Oh!
We hope that our aid has helped push you to achieve greater
things.
All mind exists for all mercenaries.
I did it.
Yeah.
All right, next victim.
we're ranked b now
we're ranked b thank god i'm using simulation missiles so i
don't lose money third squad leader of the vespers the
archivist groups augmented human squad o'keef is originally
a member of an older generation of augmented humans and
during the island's four disturbance he worked as an agent
carried on espionage activities he was later headhunted by
our archivist's information department and agreed to sign up
on the conditions that he provided him with generation 9's
augmentation surgery to counteract the coral burning on his
brain all right I'll have a lot of other shit but I want to
spend it all at once number 12 get that high get that
serotonin of retail therapy high wait he doesn't look that
fast Yeah, he's hovering.
You can't out hover my missiles.
I can shoot a flyer down, guys.
It's fine.
Look at, look at.
Okay, never mind.
He dodges.
Oh, but then he dodged this, though.
Oh, shit.
Wait, he's anti-flying me now.
Or I can't dodge this forever.
Boom!
Oh god.
Oh, I did not mean to do that.
Oh, come on!
There you go.
I'm not even a flyer!
Are you kidding me?
That's fucking... You had two shields!
I'll shield two!
You know what?
Fucking double shield!
There we go.
That's right.
You gonna shield?
I shield.
We share our shields together.
I was like, I'm a tank.
Why are you putting me?
Why are you, like, shooting me down from the sky?
I miss all I have.
I tend to be, like, above the ground for, like, 10
centimeters, and he still tries to shoot me down.
wouldn't even let me feel the air for five seconds
all right cinder carla carla oh this guy looks like a
transformer oh wait it's a spider lady
the ringleader of red and chief engineer responsible for the
basic specification of all the organization's products a
specialist in data processing and machine she's a nerd she
can't be that good, right?
But she is a nerd that can invent new nerdy gadgets, so
maybe she is pretty hard.
There's a lot of sentry and fanciful.
Yeah, as we say, she's a nerd, but like, she's a nerd and a
robot.
So, yeah, I was going to say her weapons might be a lot
better.
Quite unlike those found in the corporate catalog, her state
design philosophy is, what use this killing machine that
can't get
Mm-hmm.
All right.
I finished my food.
I'm, yeah, I was gonna say, is she Tony Stark nerd or Bruce
Banner without the Hulk nerd?
Arena Combat Aptitude Evaluation Program.
Number 11.
Rank, what is this?
What?
I had a creepy to go around ranking straight.
Rangers don't you think well whatever she's a simulation why
is she talking back I'm busy but you can have this old data
oh okay I was gonna say is she not a simulation why did she
gain sentience okay it looks like she can fly how fast is
she oh my god it doesn't matter how fast is it doesn't
matter Oh wait, maybe it does matter.
Quit.
No!
Where did Carla go?
Where did she go?
Oh my god.
No, it doesn't matter.
Come on.
Are you kidding me?
Carla, come back here!
You
bitch!
I'm trying to out-boom her.
She out-boomed me.
She had more boons.
It's Stokey Nerd.
Oh, Dana, by the way.
It's Stokey Nerd versus Stokey Bird.
Whoever wins, that's the last laugh.
I'll have the last laugh.
five oh my god it's gonna log your five oh my god i thought
i could dodge it where did she go wait where did she go i
lost it oh my god carla you fucking whore you're a little
bitch you're a coward a real boom boom supremacist would
take those booms and set play like a little bitch you're a
little bitch Carla you don't live the boom life you deserve
the booms you deserve it you fight like a goddamn bitch oh
my god miss I actually miss I'm so mad look she's only
winning cuz she's not she doesn't embrace the boom life
She's not a real boom purist.
I missed like 20 times.
I missed like 80 times already.
I do miss.
I missed every sword.
I missed everything.
Boom turrets.
Oh, shake my head.
Get this turrets out of here.
Shake.
Main system.
Activating combat mode.
Like, ow, how to dodge that?
How, how, how?
There we go.
There I did.
It's fine.
Oh, this is not fair.
She's always so far from me.
I'm trying to hit her.
There we go!
There we go.
Here's the data contained an unauthorized message.
We apologize.
She's like, wait a minute.
It's not supposed to watch.
First try.
Alright, nice.
Easy.
See, nothing to worry about.
Alright, I got her spot or emblem too.
What even is her build?
I don't even know.
I...
so many stuff now what is it is it from my assembly do i
even have anything from my build
i'm spending it all at once after i kill everything i'll
spend it
just so i can feel a serotonin rush when i spend everything
an independent mercenary who bargained his way into an
effortless entry to rubicon have anticipated the extra
planetary uh corporations forays well before they made their
move a specialist in um how are so overburdened it's because
like just just want to carry all the booms you know
just guys guys it's so hard have like it's the sacrifice you
make okay guys it's the Sacrifices you have to make.
A specialist in...
I need the heavy firepower.
No boom left behind, guys.
No boom now.
A specialist in corporate network removes underside of
elements on behalf of those who do not wish to be seen of
getting their hands dirty.
Quick to identify fellow assassin.
He claims that you can smell a real killer.
through their AC.
Not me.
I'm doing it for the greater good.
If it works, it works, guys.
Oh, rank 10.
I'm getting to the top 10 marks now.
Oh, this guy looks fast.
I'm a little worried.
This guy may or may not be fast.
He does have grasshopper legs.
Main system.
Activating combat mode.
Alright, there he is.
How fast is he?
Holy shit.
Okay, he's not as fast as I thought.
Which is good.
Oh, but he does have...
Oh.
Oh my god, never mind.
Never mind.
He doesn't need to be fast.
He can just jump everywhere.
He actually does not need to be fast.
Oh, he's top... Oh my god, he's top 10 for a reason.
He has stopped it.
Oh, where is he?
Where is he?
I do not know where Oh my god.
Oh
Okay, okay, wait, I'm downloading his data.
I'm downloading his data right now.
That was Look guys guys.
I'm just I'm just learning.
I'm learning.
I'm like AI Each attempt I build more Build more intel.
I just need to hit him once.
He might be fast.
But it's just like the other fast boy.
I just need to...
Oh my god.
I just need to hit you once.
That's all I need.
As long...
Oh my god.
As...
It is the very...
Hit is the key word here.
Hit is the key word.
Oh my god.
It is the key word.
But that's all I need.
That's all I need.
There!
I told you!
I swatted to fly down.
Fly down.
I got the swatted.
I got it in.
I told you.
I just need I just need one hit I just need one hit I told
you I fucking told you let it ride it connected it's all I
need not even close I told you I just I was machine learning
it's that easy all right oh it's rusty now it's my pal wait
isn't rusty fast as fuck
my plot armor kicked in guys the paypal went through poor
squad leader of the vespers uh the court archivist's group
augmented human squad discovered through the report
recruitment program after but operated by schnainer on
aquaribus affiliate rusty so quickly distinguished himself
that he was selected to chillins of vespers since less than
half a year rusty received augmentation surgery prior during
the vespers though the precise details are unclear he has
declared himself to be an eighth generation i'll quote wait
i can be as cool as rusty
guys i'm gonna be just as cool as him rank b
subject ac steel haze call sign v4 rusty Oh my way his
emblem is actually so fucking cool.
You will never be as cool as Resty.
Oh yeah, Fett!
I know I just have to, I'm just gonna skinwalk him.
Oh shit, okay.
Wait.
Oh my god, he's so lucky.
He's so fucking lucky.
Where is he?
He cheated!
Did you not see that?
Oh my god.
Fucking bitch.
Oh, you are a bitch.
You are a bitch.
That's right, get closer.
Oh, you're a bitch.
You're running away because you know.
You know you're so fucked.
Oh, you fucking know!
That's right, Rusty!
You might be cool, but at least I'm alive.
I might not have your swag, but at least I ain't dead.
Rusty is still so cool.
Even in death, he's so cool.
Get face taked.
Nice.
goodbye rusty all right one last one in group b the honest
brute leader of the junker coyotes a major dozer force brew
was originally hired by rad his smooth talking affable
nature quickly caught attention of Carla who found him quite
unlike the average dozer once discovered that a man was a
psychopath and a pathological liar he fled taking
considerable amount of rats fun and technology with him a
loss that's too great for Carla to tolerate oh shit oh shit
this guy is this guy might be bipolar
or a psychopath honestly hey that guy is crazy aptitude
evaluation program number eight rank b final evaluation He
looks slow.
Oh,
that's funny.
Oh, my God.
How did he make that emblem?
We had, like, squares, circles, and numbers and letters.
How did he draw that?
His emblem has shading.
Yeah, that guy's fucking crazy.
Bro, his emblem has shading.
I'm going to use shield if he's going to fucking...
flow fire at me.
Okay, that's not fair.
He literally
is...
I can't see!
If it's just it's just off fire.
I legitimately can't see.
Oh my god.
He's just blowing fire in my face.
Where is he?
Where...
He's cheating!
Oh my god, where is he now?
Where... Where is he now?
No!
Quit doing it.
I can't see anything!
He's... Why is he so funny?
Like, it's just...
It's like I'm playing Overwatch or Rivals right now.
And, like, my entire screen is just cluttered.
Like, where is anything?
Like, where is he?
Where?
Okay, there he is.
There he is.
I see him.
I see him now.
Where is...
Oh, my God.
I lost him again.
I lost him.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I hate this fight.
This fight is...
This fight is terrible.
I...
That's all for me.
Did he go?
Wait, y'all.
This fight is terrible.
I threw a fire in the flames.
No, you know what?
No, I'm playing Valorant right now.
Like, they threw, like, 80...
80 stuns at me.
You saw it.
Who would have thought fire was her weakness?
Agent, thank you, sir.
Chat, thank you.
standing so wait oh my god I can't even standing in the
close place
as long as he doesn't use it where where did he go where did
he go where did he go is this is that him okay that's him oh
he's doing it oh my god he did it back to me he he did it
back to me me it's not fair his ai doesn't need this it's
not fair okay wait wait i think i figured it out i think i
figured it out
is it you just did it
guys i figured it out
Where did he go?
You guys, I swear to God I figured it out.
I'm just, I figured it out.
Where did he go?
I, did I hit him?
Did I, oh, he got me though.
He got, he got me.
Where did he go?
There's a time.
Where is he?
I don't think I figured it out.
Guys, I...
Alright.
Guys, guys.
No, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
I just gotta play like how I did the first time.
However I played it.
mode
oh my god fucky course oh
my god please get me out of here please get me out of here
oh I can't I can't deal with this why every time I stun him
no no no You bitch!
You whore!
You fuck you whore!
Okay.
It's okay.
Okay, it's okay.
Main system.
Activating combat mode.
It's because he's cheating!
Boom!
Alright.
flame sword this now bitch oh my god that's right where did
he go oh my god where did he go
oh my god oh my god
he's out he's out Raid boss down.
Raid a boss down.
I told you I figured it out.
I told you.
Yes.
I did it.
I figured out the algorithm.
Now look at me go.
Look at me go.
Now I can cash in.
I put him in the corner.
I did learn.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
I have.
It is a great honor to witness your evolution as a
mercenary.
All mind exists for all mercenaries.
All right.
Now, I wish I...
I feel like I should get healers, right?
I'm gonna grab a healers.
I'm gonna grab heals first.
I feel like I need that the most.
All right.
What else should I...
Oh, wait, the shield, right?
I can get two?
Is this?
I have another one.
I have another to grab.
Oh, I can't.
Oh, wait.
Saw armor.
Unlocks the saw armor.
Wait, is it not this?
Oh, wait.
That's this.
Oh, my God.
I bought the wrong one.
Whoops.
All right.
Never mind.
I got it.
Whoops.
I might have wasted my money there, but that's okay.
It was this.
Um, what else should we get?
I have a lot of money now.
Proofs object access speed by...
Should we get that?
Dynamic control...
Oh, I can refund?
Oh, refund.
It's all armor.
Oh, here it is.
Reset.
Expand and reset OS upgrade.
Wait, I don't want to reset everything.
Does it reset this or does it reset everything?
Explosive weapon upgrade?
Is this one?
Oh, yeah, that one.
Oh, I don't want to reset everything.
It's fine.
I'll put it all in.
You know what?
We'll do one more.
No, it's fine.
We do that and then...
Should we go all in on explosive weapons?
We
go all in All in, you're right Well, not all, never mind
Wait, melee weapon That's my pulse, right?
Is that my pulse?
My pile driver?
Sorry, my pile driver Sorry, my pile driver
Alright, we'll grab that Alright Our explosive and melee
Alright, now Now Now array the fuck.
Alright, let's see.
Eliminate.
Honest.
Yeah, no, I just fought this guy.
No, it's fine.
You know what?
No.
I think I can do it again.
Fuck that.
Round two.
Rematch death.
I got the download in.
That institute relic you had a run in with.
The corpse might stand a chance if it were just the PCA they
were teaming up against.
But that monster is a whole other story.
You can't just throw bodies at it.
Yeah, I get to do it for real.
The thing that makes it such a pain in the ass is to protect
the real thing.
Coral tech.
Takes advantage of the corals' directivity.
Ordinary weapons can't touch it.
So let's get extraordinary.
Alright, here we go.
I think that'll punch a hole in that shoe.
I like the sound of that.
You'll be heading to Grid 012.
That sounds optimal.
That's barely holding up.
That's where a little rat who betrayed our ID is hiding out.
Goes by the name of Honest Brute.
Oh, Carla hates him.
His AC Milk Tooth was built by us.
So it's only flaws that it's planted by him.
And just take credits in tech.
He also took a secret project of mine And that secret
project is what we'll need to bust open the ice worm shield.
Okay What's the needle launcher?
Why do I need a needle launcher?
What even is a needle launcher?
All right, here we go You ready for this tourist?
No one's gonna miss that's a secret weapon and we all stand
to gain
That was a secret project, right?
I'm ready.
I'm ready for the rematch It's a delight to enjoy the
company of a visitor from so far away Oh, where is he
sounds like a very nice guy oh
no he's gonna rage bait me I wonder why I'm so slow how can
I fix that guys oh that's cheating I don't even know where
he is oh
shit oh shit what's going on
oh no i took so much damage whoops
all right it's fine the damn freaks using my toys like they
were his okay maybe it's no longer five I feel like I'm
gonna get gunned down guys I don't think it's fine anymore
make sure you keep clear of the laser sensors they're set to
activate the enemy machines okay I blow it up yes I can
now.
Okay, it's this way.
I'll just slowly...
Okay.
As long as I don't get blown up!
Chicken!
Guys, I might have gotten blown up.
Guys, I might have gotten blown up, guys.
Just a maybe.
Alright.
Here, I can fight him now.
Right here.
This must be where he is.
There he is.
I see him.
That's not him.
I daked it because I thought it was him.
I was like, I'll take one shot.
It's fine.
I was like, it's fine.
That's him, right?
It was not him, guys.
It was absolutely not him.
Oh.
Who could have known?
Wait, I could have known.
It was me.
I could have known.
Oh, no.
I thought it was him.
Alright, zero repair kits.
Oh, quick, quick.
No, oh, there he is.
I know, Milk Tooth.
I can't wait either.
These things are rather strange.
No repair kits remaining.
Oh.
Oh, I don't...
It's alright.
We don't need that.
I hate to see my babies get scrapped like this, you know.
Well, don't be shy.
Smash them up.
They'll help me with my R&P.
Oh.
Oh, all right, whatever you say.
Oh, I have to go in.
I'm dumb.
There we go.
Maybe there'll be a resupply kit.
Guys?
Maybe?
Maybe there's a resupply kit nearby.
Yeah, ha ha.
There's your way in.
right slow slow
whoops well now i can definitely hit it
oh i'll land right here in this corner i've done my best
what the fuck they like move what
is that i'll get that out of the way because i don't know
what this is
is that oh it's just a part where am i supposed to go
what oh okay where is it down oh it's over here
all right i was like where's the hole
no no no no whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
There we go.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, no, I'm sorry
That's okay Oh, it's no longer okay Oh,
where am I supposed to jump down?
Oh, that's awkward.
That's fine.
That's awkward.
No, that was awkward But it's okay
all right so that there's a resupply here right there's a
resupply here right guys don't worry we're gonna have a
resupply right here any second now and oh my Oh my god.
Just like old time.
Where did he go?
Oh my god.
Just like old time.
Oh goodbye.
Feels just like old time.
It's okay.
It was just a test run, guys.
We were learning, you know, AI learning again.
But, see, just like, see, I told you there's a resupply.
I told you guys
I'm just resupplying
I told you My new friend You're here at last Where did he
go?
Oh my god Not again Not again Oh
Where is he?
Where did he go?
It's not fair!
It's fine.
You bitch!
Don't worry.
I just gotta get you in a corner.
I just gotta figure out where you went.
Where did you go?
And where did you go?
There you go.
Oh fuck.
I didn't even see my HP just now.
Where did he heal?
Where did he go?
Oh my god, you bitch.
Where did he get my entire game?
It's just where is he?
I don't care.
I'm just gonna slap you.
Get out of here.
Here we go.
See?
I figured it out.
I knew I knew where he was guys I knew where he I was using
echo location that's why I was shouting it out every time
but I say where is he my echo location was bouncing off of
his body I told you oh that was a lot of money that was a
lot Oh, that was...
Wow, where did the money go?
One new message.
This is Chattie Stick, R-A-D.
Thanks for putting down Brute.
The chief's already in the workshop tweaking the rail
cannon.
And I've never seen her happier to be at work.
That is all.
Later, tourist.
Oh, yeah, thanking us.
out.
No need to thank me.
I know I'm that good.
You see, I won't use the same flamethrower myself because
unlike AI, I feel like they would be able to see it past the
flamethrower.
I just could not see.
I don't think the AI uses the eyes that I have.
Alright, defend the old spaceport and prevent its recapture
by the Planetary Closure Administration.
Salvage Historic Data.
I'm going to do one more today.
And I'm going to call it here because I think I'm straining
my voice.
I'm straining my voice a little bit too much.
So I'll do one more level.
The spaceport?
All right.
I'll do the spaceport.
Got a job for you, 621.
We've received a request from the Archivist Group.
Raven this request comes from our subsidiary Schneider Yeah,
the echo location I might have I might have echoed too much
of my location We were brought under our control We've
received intel that a stranded PCA fleet is planning to
retake the base Your objective is to intercept the PCA and
defend the spaceport We're deployed an empty squad to
support you Use them as you see fit Nice.
Got a crew.
Got my own crew.
Alright.
Defending a spaceport.
Can't be too bad.
I did really well in last defense.
After I locked in and stopped fucking around.
Yeah, I have hope.
You have a squad.
Just a simple defense mission.
How hard can it get?
Alright.
Commence mission.
Wait, something's not right, 621.
Yeah, where's my army?
The battle's over already.
Yeah, what?
Find out what's going on.
Wait, people already fly here.
I did it, guys.
Meow.
Drop done.
Where's my army?
Oh?
There's a giant robot standing far in the distance.
Is he part of my crew?
He looks friendly, right?
What?
That's a little boy?
Wait, he's alive?
I thought I killed him!
you know he actually looks like a raven compared to me oh
that's bad oh that's bad wait how did you live wait
how did he live I killed you oh shit oh my god what he
pierced my shield
what is that not the little oh my god I literally shielded
it and then he fucking stabbed through my shield oh I grave
robbed him wait it's just not the little boy I killed oh
it's the other guy it's the guy I fucking stole the license
from.
Who's the?
I thought it was the test pilot.
Oh, okay.
It's the one I stole the license to enter the place.
Yeah.
Identity theft is a crime, dokey.
Margarita, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, that's the first mission.
I thought you were dead!
Oh, shit.
Oh, shit, he's gonna...
Oh, shit!
Oh, he is...
He might be a little better than me, guys!
The original may or may not!
Oh, I thought... Oh, no, he's gonna do it.
He's gonna... No!
Oh, my god!
Oh, my god, that's not fair!
Wait, did he get healed too?
That's cheating!
Oh my god.
Please don't come hear me.
Oh, you fucker.
I'm trying.
It's so good.
it might be better
holy shit am i thought i am i not the main character what i
thought i thought i was i thought i was the main character i
was i never the main kicked you all along?
Never were.
You were just an imposter.
I was just a ditto in a Pikachu's world.
I'm just poor little Mimikyu.
This isn't my story.
That AC do all this.
What?
There's no way you just tanked that.
Oh my god, don't worry.
He can't make it close enough.
It's not fair.
He's so high up.
50%.
AP has 30%.
Oh my god.
He's so good.
AP at 30%.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Did you think it's not what you think I'm doing?
Is that not what you think I'm doing, sir?
Holy shit, it's okay.
Oh my god, he has everything!
He has everything!
isn't over yet raylon oh my god he does so much does so much
he took back his plot armor
oh my god i thought he was dead how is i supposed to know he
took back his plot army
okay yeah oh my god okay
Oh my god, he healed again, too.
Did I hit him?
I don't know if I hit him.
Jesus, I'm trying!
I'm trying, sir!
I swear to God, I ain't fucking around, sir, I swear!
Oh my god.
out of PCA squad.
Stay sharp since 2-1.
Oh, this is the most I've ever done.
Oh my god.
Ah!
Wait, where did he go?
My lock thing didn't work!
No!
He did just wait wait i'm downloading though i'm downloading
i'm downloading the gameplay this is the best run yet this
is the best run yet he has so much heals i think he has more
heals than me there is no way he commence mission wait
something's not right six two one i'm trying not to move my
mouse but it's so hard find out what's going on because it's
like it feels like he was moving faster than my lock-in
whoops all right I'm not moving my mouse
okay oh my god but I want and you do that too okay
I did move my mouse there oh my god He got me.
He got me.
How does...
Oh, my God.
Did I get him?
No, I did not.
Oh, but he's got me.
Oh, you fucker.
Just focus on the fight six to one.
I'm trying.
Okay.
You bitch.
You're safe.
Such a bitch.
You're such a bitch.
You're You're a whore
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
We're getting a little okay.
I might have to be less heavier This might be Might be the
time where I might have to be less heavy this Yeah
Okay, we might have to have smaller arms.
How?
My arms are so tiny!
How can my arms get tinier?
Okay, there we go.
Alright.
There we go.
My arms are...
My arms are tinier now.
My arms are tinier.
Oh, God.
I don't know if it feels any different.
Guys, it's okay.
My arms are tiny, though.
Guys, I'm so fast.
I'm so fast, though.
Oh, God.
Looks like we found your license is original, however.
Tie up the loose end.
I'm locking it out.
There you go.
My turn!
Okay.
Oh my god, you bitch!
Where did she go?
I feel it too.
Here we go.
My turn.
My turn again.
No repair kits remaining.
Okay.
Yes!
I just needed lighter arms.
That's right.
Yes!
I am the Raven now.
Boom!
Let's like go!
I just needed to stop doing my arm game.
I just needed to skip arm day.
There we go.
I'm you now.
Now I can do identity theft.
I am Raven now.
No new messages.
This is my plot army.
My tiny arms wood.
The independent mercenary who attacked you.
It turns out that Raven isn't an individual call sign.
It's a title.
Passed down generations of mercenaries who champion the free
will Raven stands for.
Oh, now I'm Raven.
Wait, I earned Raven now!
Yeah, I earned it!
That's what being Raven means.
Then that's the name I want to keep calling you.
Raven.
This.
So it's not death.
I earned this.
Alright, let's apparently have to buy whatever arms, a
boncho arms or whatever.
This one?
Basho?
It's like 81,000 though Now I full now now it's real now I
can put it on my ID It was theft, but now now it's okay now
now.
It's fine.
All right, I earned this I wear my new arms There we go.
All right, yeah, I'm gonna call it here.
I think I think this was a good stopping point
What do you fight for, Jokey?
For.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I like money.
Whoever pays me enough, I'll fight for you.
Amen.
I fight for money and big abooms.
Whoever gives me enough money to buy.
more booms you get to hire me spoken like a true raven look
all i'm saying is that money lets me purchase more booms so
i could do more big booms you're a raven now fly far fly
fast and make loads of dollars.
Thank you, the super chat.
Marita, thank you, thank you.
Monster, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you all for coming to today's stream.
I'm sorry I couldn't do a longer stream today.
I would love to play more armor core right now, but my voice
feels very, very strained, and I feel like this was a really
good stopping point, too.
You know?
It didn't take me that many tries.
I was literally just not fast enough.
I tried.
I had to finally swap my arms to, like, get the weight down.
The moment I did it, I fucking downloaded her.
I was like, that's right.
Can't keep up now, can you?
Just needed a little bit more speed.
But anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated,
posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve
it.
of it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.